I have a huge scar on my spine and two on
my abdomen, but whenever I spend time in the
Sun they turn bright red, and I’ve always
wondered why?
Hello everyone, proud scar owner Amy with
you on DNews today!
Scars are our body’s way of recovering from
trauma.
Whenever body tissue is broken, it heals itself
by producing more collagen to fix the damage.
For about three months, this process draws
more blood to the area, which is why scars
start red, and eventually fade to pale.
In the end, the new tissue heals into a scar,
and you're left with a permanent reminder
of whatever happened on that one night in
Vegas.
But why do scars not look like the rest of
your skin?
Our individual skin colour is determined by
a pigment called melanin.
It’s made by specialized cells in our skin
called melanocytes, in organelles called melanosomes.
The type and amount of melanin gives skin
its individual colour: more melanin, darker
color, less, lighter.
The amount of melanin is dependent on your
ethnicity, environment, and hormone levels.
But, it can also change with exposure to the
UV radiation in sunlight.
Tanning, which we’ve discussed before, is
the skin’s way of protecting itself against
ultraviolet light.
Certain skin cells produce more melanin the
longer you spend in the Sun.
The darker pigment absorbs UV radiation so
it can't penetrate the skin any further, which
sounds great except that too much radiation
damages the skin causing what we know as a
sun burn.
The thing is… scar tissue doesn't do this!
Scar tissue doesn’t have melanin, so doesn’t
have pigment!
The reason why is actually a bit of a mystery
to scientists.
But one study I found in the Indian Journal
of Plastic Surgery suggests that the availability
of melanocytes to repigment scarred skin depends
on the mechanism of the injury.
Superficial injuries retain the cells adjacent
to the wounded area, but deep cuts destroy
more elements, meaning the only available
source for melanocytes are the wound’s edges.
So, deeper injuries take longer to heal and
end up with a lighter, melanin-free center
compared to the surrounding skin.
And because they lack melanin, the cells that
form scars can’t produce more of it!
So when a scar is exposed to sunlight, it
just can’t tan.
And this doesn’t only make the scar stand
out more, it also puts the scar owner at an
increased risk of UV-related skin damage!
I’ve noticed this myself.
My scars turn red really fast if I don't put
sunscreen on them.
Another odd thing about scars?
They're typically hairless.
And like a lack of pigment, this has to do
with how damaged the skin is.
Hair grows from the papilla, the living part
of the hair follicle inside the skin.
When the skin is damaged deeply enough to
disrupt the follicle, the hair can’t grow.
So, scars don't tan and don't grow hair, but
why are some more visible than others?
Skin cells grow in specific directions in
different parts of your body.
A cut made with the grain will heal into a
much thinner scar than one made against the
grain.
What all this boils down to is that scars,
for a lot of people, are unsightly and make
them feel ugly, but they’re really evidence
of how incredible our bodies are at taking
care of themselves.
Speaking of scars, did you guys know Al Bean
got smacked in the head with a camera when
Apollo 12 splashed down and ended up with
a nice little scar on his forehead?
True story, and that’s not the weirdest
space fact I could throw at you!
If you’re a sucker for old things in space
come check out my channel, Vintage Space,
where I dig into all kinds of minutiae relating
to America’s Moonshot!
My scars came from surgeries after a car accident
when I was a kid, and I wear them proud!
What about you guys?
Tell us your scar-y stories in the comments
and make sure you subscribe so you never miss
an episode of DNews.